هنا الحي التاريخي في نورمبرج وعلى مقربه
منه عاشت المدينه اكبر محاكمات لقاده
النازيه او ما يعرف بالرايخ الثالث بعد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
الشعارات الامبراطوريه وبصمات الرايخ
شاهده على ما حدث وبعد اكثر من 70 عاما
تعود من المكان نفسه حركه مواطني الرايخ
تعد نفسها امتدادا لنظام من حكم سابقا هنا
وتحولت هذه المدينه الى اهم قاعده لحركه
التي تصفها السلطات بالارهابيه
تمت قدر هائل من الخطر في بنيه حركه مواطن
ريخ كثير من افرادها لديهم تصاريح بحيازه
اسلحه ومترسون على استخدامها
هذا هو الدكتور فولف جانجر هارد كونتر
ايبل الذي اسس الحركه باسم حكومه الرايخ
المؤقته متبنيا نظريات المؤامره ومعاداه
الساميه والعنصريه
اسست الحركه في ثمانينه القرن الماضي
وتتكون من جناحين مدني وعسكري تعد الحركه
نفسها امتدادا للحقبه النازيه ويلتهم
اعضاءها جمهوريه المانيا الاتحاديه بانها
اسست بصوره غير قانونيه لا يعترف اعضاء
الحركه بالدوله الحاليه وقوانينها
ومؤسساتها مثل المحاكم والسلطات الحكوميه
يرفضون دفع الضرائب ويعتقدون ان
الامبراطوريه الالمانيه لا تزال قائمه
ينحدر معظم اعضاءها من ولايه بافاري
وبابنه جنوبيه البلاد
واغلبيتهم من الفقراء الذين يبلغ متوسط
اعمارهم 50 عاما وقد بلغ عدد اعضاء الحركه
عام 20 نحو 19000 حسب السلطات الالمانيه
باتباع مواطني الروايخ الى الشارع بقوه
كلما دعت الحاجه حاملين هويات خاصه بهم
تعكس انتمائهم الى امبراطوريه رائعه
الحلفاء جمهوريه المانيا الاتحاديه في
الامم المتحده كم منظمه غير حكوميه
المتطرف الى قواعد اجتماعيه ومؤسسات
الحكوميه حتى اخترق وحده النخبه في الجيش
الالماني ووصلت امتداداته الى البستان
عمليه عمليه في تاريخها لمواجهتها انصار
حركه مواطنيه الرائق المتطرفه مواجهتنا
امنيه تتزامن مع مواجهه للذاكره الدمويه
لسقوط ثالث عام
1945 والتي يرى فيها مراقبون مبدا اصيلا
في نظره انصار الرايخ للدوله والمجتمع
يعتقدون ان رسالتهم العقائديه هي اعاده
امجاد الامه الالمانيه ولو بالقوه